foreign
it is a moment they've longed to see and
the Euphoria of Liberation was
impossible to contain
Ukrainian soldiers were given a hero's
welcome as the crowd chanted for the
military
the only Regional Capital captured by
Russia in its failing invasion was back
under kiev's control
at the police headquarters there was
also Joy with the blue and yellow of the
national flag flying proudly once again
and the speed of Ukraine's Advance on
the southern front has been staggeringly
fast
[Music]
the Russians were here and then they
were gone
endless trenches simply abandoned
in this Village selfies with soldiers
ended nine frightening months of
occupation for these women like everyone
else here it is an emotional time
and as people adjust to their New
Freedom there is an outpouring of
national pride Yuri tells me he can't
believe the Russians have left
um
but these areas are still far from safe
the soldiers here say they've already
removed more than 300 mines around the
village
this is where the Russians were
they've left an enormous amount of
ammunition
crate after crate
just dumped
they left here about 24 hours ago they
just simply vanished from this place
but you can see all the bombs down here
that they've left
has been taken over now by Ukrainian
soldiers
as they move through this Village
everywhere they go they keep finding
more ammunition more things that have
just been discarded by the Russians
in this bunker Sergey shows me rows of
mortars he says the Russians had no
choice but to leave in a hurry and it
won't be long before the rest of the
country is liberated
the Russian Retreat here is another
humiliation for Moscow abandoned
positions and uniforms now symbols of a
botched invasion
and they are already ripping down all
signs of Russia's presence
this victory for Ukraine is a big moment
but this war is far from over
Alex Rossi Sky News Kirsten region